[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es einen leckeren Kuchen,
ein Wunschrezept von Murat.
Und zwar hat der mal irgendwo ein Bild gesehen
von einem Butterkekskuchen.
Er wollte eigentlich das Ganze als No-Bake-Kuchen.
Ich war auch echt kurz davor,
einen No-Bake-Kuchen zu machen,
aber ich glaube, ich habe was Besseres im Kopf,
einen Kekskuchen mit einem leckeren Biskuit,
mit einer Fruchtschicht, Pudding und Sahne.
Richtig gut!
Wenn ihr aber sagt: "Nee, komm, das ist mir zu aufwendig,
ich will einen No-Bake-Kuchen machen",
dann lasst ihr einfach den Biskuit weg
und startet einfach nur mit der Butterkeksschicht.
Dann habt ihr No-Bake ohne Backofen,
einen Kühlschrankkuchen.
Auch sehr lecker.
Ich mache jetzt erst mal den Biskuit.
Den Ofen habe ich schon vorgeheizt
auf 200°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
Und für den Biskuit nehme ich
vier Eier,
100 Gramm Zucker,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
eine Prise Salz,
100 Gramm Mehl.
Und dann habe ich hier noch Butterkekse.
Und eigentlich bin ich eher der Fan von Vollkornbutterkeksen.
Aber da habe ich nur noch eine halbe Packung.
Deswegen nehme ich jetzt die normalen.
Und wir hatten gerade schon mit Samira
– Samira ist wieder Kamerakind zwei.
Josh ist Kamera Kind eins.
Mit Samira hatten wir gerade schon die Diskussion.
Ich liebe es ja, wenn die Kekse aufgeweicht sind.
Und ich habe die als Kind
– ich habe es geliebt, mit meinen Eltern
schwarzen Tee zu trinken, also türkischen Tee.
Gut, damals als Kind habe ich ihn noch gesüßt mit Zucker.
Und dann habe ich diesen Keks so einmal reingetunkt
– aber du darfst nicht zu lange tunken.
Denn, wenn er zu lange getunkt wird,
dann fällt der in deinen Tee rein und das ist echt eklig.
Also so kurz reintunken,
warten, bis der sich vollzieht,
und dann schnell essen.
Oh! Voll lecker!
Und Ela macht das auch.
Aber Samira mag es nicht, gell?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Hast du gerade gesagt.
Okay.
Am besten die Eier zimmerwarm verwenden.
Dann lassen sie sich besser aufschlagen.
Und ihr könnt jetzt ein Handrührgerät nehmen
oder halt eine Küchenmaschine.
Eier mit Zucker und Vanilleextrakt,
dann noch eine Prise Salz
und dann rührt ihr die Masse
in etwa 10 bis 15 Minuten richtig schön cremig.
Und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal meine Backform
mit den Butterkeksen auslegen.
[Musik]
Okay. Gerade, wo ich die Butterkekse in die Form lege,
ist mir eingefallen, ich wollte die Hälfte des Rezepts machen.
Also, wenn ihr es nachmacht,
macht es nur mit zwei Eiern
und 50 Gramm Zucker und 50 Gramm Mehl,
also die Hälfte des Biskuits.
Denn ich brauche zur heutigen Zeit
keinen Riesenblechkuchen.
Deswegen mache ich es kleiner.
Ups.
Aber ich rühre den Biskuit jetzt fertig
und nehme einfach gleich nur die Hälfte.
Und mit der anderen Hälfte backe ich einfach was anderes.
Oder Samira isst es.
So. Wunderbar cremig sieht die Eiermasse jetzt aus.
Jetzt kann ich noch das Mehl dazu sieben.
Aber das mache ich jetzt nicht mehr mit der Maschine.
Da nehme ich dann gleich einen Schneebesen.
Denn jetzt habt ihr die Eiermasse
richtig schön schaumig und cremig gerührt
und jetzt will ich ja das Mehl nur noch unterheben.
[Musik]
Einfach kurz das Mehl dazu sieben und unterheben.
Und wie gesagt, nehme ich jetzt nur die Hälfte des Teiges.
Ihr könnt auch im Prinzip die ganze Menge nehmen.
Dann habt ihr aber halt einen höheren Biskuit
und ich wollte eigentlich eher,
dass es so eine flache Schnitte wird.
Daher nehme ich jetzt die Hälfte.
[Musik]
Dann schön über den Keksen verteilen.
Und ihr könnt ja den Backrahmen wirklich super einstellen,
dass er genau exakt um die Kekse herum passt.
So. Glatt streichen.
Und direkt backen.
[Musik]
Der Kuchen durfte elf Minuten backen
und ich habe ihn jetzt hier abkühlen lassen.
Jetzt kommt hier eine Fruchtschicht drauf.
Die mache ich jetzt mit Himbeeren und Johannisbeeren
aus dem Tiefkühlfach.
Ihr könnt natürlich zur Saison auch frische Früchte benutzen
oder was ihr gerade im Tiefkühlfach habt.
Ich habe jetzt hier 350 Gramm Früchte,
30 Gramm Zucker,
5 Gramm Agar-Agar,
100 Gramm Wasser
und etwas Tonka Wonka.
Damit verfeinere ich es.
Agar-Agar ist ein pflanzliches Geliermittel,
falls ihr das nicht kennt,
und zwar einfach so ein Ersatz zur Gelatine.
Das ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Ich habe jetzt die Früchte auch schon auftauen lassen,
werde jetzt das Wasser dazu geben
und erst einmal kurz pürieren.
Ihr könnt sie aber auch, wenn ihr wollt, stückig lassen.
Also das ist so eure Entscheidung.
Ich glaube, so ein bisschen stückig lasse ich es auch.
Dann in einen Topf umfüllen.
Dann hier jetzt Zucker,
Agar-Agar und Tonka Wonka dazu geben.
Wenn ihr kein Tonka Wonka habt,
dann nehmt einfach eine Tonkabohne.
Die kann ich euch auch kurz zeigen.
Eine Tonkabohne ist im Prinzip
so ein bisschen ähnlich zur Vanilleschote,
also auch ein tolles Gewürz.
Und die gibt es entweder so als getrocknete Bohne
– und für jeden riecht Tonka ein bisschen anders.
Für mich riecht es echt nach Waldmeister,
Mandel und Vanille so ein bisschen.
Und entweder nehmt ihr, wie gesagt, die Bohne
und könnt sie dann fein reiben.
Nicht überdosieren!
Überdosiert ist Tonkabohne nämlich giftig,
genauso wie Muskatnuss oder auch Zimt.
Und, wie gesagt, entweder so oder halt als Paste.
Wir haben einfach die Paste mal herstellen lassen,
weil die Dosierung einfacher ist
und man es eben nicht mehr reinreiben muss.
Jetzt könnt ihr hier
alles schön verrühren.
Und ich finde, Tonka passt halt echt gut zu Früchten.
Ich habe mal
– und das war echt meine absolute Lieblingsmarmelade.
Als ich das Backbuch letztes Jahr gemacht habe
– war das letztes oder vorletztes Jahr?
2019,
nicht 20.
Es war 19, in Sarahs erstem Jahr. Ja.
Und da habe ich
– am Ende der Backbuchproduktion
hatte ich halt echt viel Obst übrig,
Obst und Früchte und alles.
Und dann habe gesagt,
komm, ich mache jetzt einfach eine Marmelade,
und habe alles in einen Topf geschmissen
und dann ein bisschen Tonka dazu.
Und es war so lecker!
Es war die leckerste Marmelade.
Und weil ich eben kein Rezept dazu habe,
habe ich sie nie wieder so lecker hingekriegt.
Aber ich glaube, ich nehme einfach
jetzt auch wieder im Sommer alles,
packe es rein und mache eine Marmelade daraus.
Jetzt hier diese Fruchtmischung...
Ich koche gerade nebenher übrigens.
Jetzt hier diese Fruchtmischung aufkochen lassen
und dann zwei Minuten lang sprudelnd kochen lassen,
damit das Agar-Agar eben auch wirken kann.
[Musik]
Die Masse durfte jetzt kochen
und ich habe sie auch kurz ein bisschen abkühlen lassen,
dass sie nicht so ganz heiß ist.
Ihr habt ja hier den Kuchen.
Den nicht vom Rand lösen.
Der einzige Grund, warum ich ihn ein bisschen lösen werde,
ist, weil ihr seht es vielleicht hier,
dass der Biskuit am Rand so ein bisschen hochklebt.
Und wenn jetzt die Masse draufkommt
– ich will es halt sauber,
also dass es halt sauber aussieht.
Ihr könnt es einfach jetzt so drübergießen.
Das ist bei mir jetzt eher was Optisches,
dass ich hier den Rand so leicht löse
und auch gar nicht komplett bis runter.
[Musik]
Und jetzt hier vorsichtig drübergießen
und gleich gleichmäßig verteilen.
Der Vorteil von Agar-Agar ist nämlich auch,
dass es schneller fest wird als Gelatine,
wirklich auch schon bei Raumtemperatur
und sogar noch wärmer.
Also es geliert schneller, wird schneller fest.
Man hat nicht so lange Wartezeiten.
Und, wie gesagt, rein pflanzlich.
Und dann kann ich jetzt hier den Kuchen
in den Kühlschrank geben
und in der Zwischenzeit schon mal den Pudding vorbereiten.
Denn der Pudding, das wird die nächste Schicht.
Okay, ich habe jetzt keine Gelierprobe gemacht, aber...
Ach, ich hoffe jetzt einfach, es wird fest.
Normalerweise mache ich immer eine Gelierprobe.
Wenn euch das hier zu viel ist mit der Fruchtmasse,
könnt ihr auch Marmelade draufstreichen.
Aber diese Fruchtmasse hat den Vorteil,
ihr könnt halt den Zuckergehalt selber bestimmen
und könnt so eben auch bestimmen,
wie süß oder sauer ihr es haben wollt.
Und ich finde, das sollte jetzt schon
so ein säuerlicher Ausgleich zur süßen Creme gleich haben
oder sein.
Okidoki.
Jetzt ist die Fruchtschicht fest
und die Puddingschicht ist an der Reihe.
Dafür mache ich einen ganz normalen Vanillepudding
aus 500 Gramm Milch,
zwei Eigelben,
45 Gramm Stärke,
40 Gramm Zucker
und Vanilleextrakt.
Und im Prinzip gebt ihr dafür
alle Zutaten in einen Topf und verrührt sie.
Am besten sogar erst Eigelb, Stärke
und Zucker.
Dann ein bisschen Milch.
Ups. Jetzt habe ich voll gekleckert.
Kurz klümpchenfrei verrühren.
Und dann die restliche Milch dazu gießen,
Vanilleextrakt dazu
und dann auf dem Herd bei mittelhoher Hitze
während des Rühren aufkochen lassen,
damit der Pudding schön eindickt.
[Musik]
Der Pudding darf jetzt hier auch einmal aufkochen.
Und schaut mal. So schön cremig soll er dann aussehen.
Und den lasse ich jetzt hier
so etwa fünf bis zehn Minuten abkühlen,
rühre immer mal durch.
Er soll noch warm sein, aber nicht heiß sein,
wenn ich ihn über die Fruchtmasse gieße.
>> SAMIRA: Ist das ein Vanillepudding?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Lecker, gell?
Und dann kommt der noch warme Pudding
auf den Kuchen, wird glatt gestrichen.
Und dann muss der Kuchen wirklich komplett durchkühlen.
Denn die nächste Schicht ist eine Sahneschicht
und die möchte nicht
auf einen lauwarmen Untergrund.
Die will es kalt.
Das ist schon ein cooler Schicht-Keks-Kuchen.
Ja.
>> SAMIRA: Den würde ich auf jeden Fall probieren.
>> SALLY: Echt?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay. Wenn Samira sagt, sie würde ihn probieren,
dann habe ich was richtig gemacht.
[Musik]
Der Puddingkuchen ist jetzt kalt.
Jetzt kommt noch die Sahneschicht.
Und dafür nehme ich jetzt
250 Gramm Quark,
80 Gramm Puderzucker,
ein bisschen Zitronensaft und Vanilleextrakt,
500 Gramm Sahne
und etwa siebeneinhalb bis acht Teelöffel San-apart.
Und ich gebe dann immer ganz gerne
zuerst den Quark in die Rührschüssel.
Ich muss sagen, früher habe ich, wenn ich gebacken habe,
immer erst mal die Sahne steif geschlagen,
dann die Quarkmasse verrührt,
dann untergehoben.
Aber ich bin da irgendwann echt davon weg,
weil ich gedacht habe, so mit San-apart
kann man alles gemeinsam steif schlagen
und spart sich einen Arbeitsschritt.
Deswegen schaue ich nur immer, dass ich den Quark
mit dem Puderzucker verrühre,
dass der sich schon mal ein bisschen auflösen kann.
Ich gebe ein bisschen Zitronensaft dazu,
so einen Teelöffel ungefähr.
Ihr könnt auch den Zitronenabrieb dazu geben,
aber ich finde, der passt jetzt hier nicht so gut.
Vanille passt halt immer.
[Musik]
Und jetzt schon mal etwas verrühren,
die Sahne zugießen
und dann mit San-apart steif schlagen.
[Musik]
So sieht die Sahne jetzt aus.
Boah, das war richtig ASMR!
[Musik]
Jetzt die Sahne schön verstreichen.
Und gerne auch hier den Rand säubern.
[Musik]
Und jetzt kommt der krönende Abschluss:
der Butterkeks.
Der wird jetzt hier auch schön hingelegt.
Ich könnte es jetzt so machen,
keine Produktplatzierung.
Das ist keine bezahlte Produktplatzierung.
Aber es sieht schöner aus,
wenn man drauf lesen kann.
Und natürlich darauf achten, wenn ihr vorher die Kekse
– also das Blech wieder so hinstellen, wie es vorher war,
damit die Kekse unten und oben eben auch gleich sind.
[Musik]
Und jetzt leicht andrücken.
Und so ist die Schnitte im Prinzip fertig,
darf noch in den Kühlschrank, damit ich sie gleich,
wenn sie geschnitten wird, einfach schön kalt habe.
Ihr könnt die auch schon am Tag vorher zubereiten
und jetzt einfach gut abdecken.
Und dann schneiden wir und probieren wir sie.
War doch echt easy.
Jetzt kann die Schnitte verkostet werden.
>> MURAT: Und, wo wir es gerade bei Schnitte haben,
ich bin auch mal wieder da.
Wahnsinn! Ja.
Ich bin schon lang nicht mehr da gewesen,
weil im Gegensatz zu meiner Frau,
die hier ihrem Hobby nachgehen darf jeden Tag,
>> SALLY: Jeden Tag Hobby von morgens bis abends.
>> MURAT: bin ich auf Baustelle und muss arbeiten.
Ja.
Deswegen eher seltener da.
>> SALLY: Deswegen brauchst du aber nicht...
>> MURAT: Oh! Wieder was Gesundes!
>> SALLY: Nur, weil du auf der Baustelle warst,
brauchst du nicht aufhören, Artikel zu benutzen.
Jetzt war ich auf der Baustelle.
>> MURAT: Ja, auf der Baustelle.
Wieder was Gesundes, ja?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Grüße gehen raus übrigens an unsere Partner,
an die Zahnärztekammer Reutlingen
und den Adipositas Verband in Passau.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Der Josh feiert das.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Das sind so...
Ab und zu mal muss es mal sein.
Ich weiß ganz genau, dass irgendwelche Leute,
die hier gerade an der Kamera sind
oder halt hinter der Kamera, sagen:
"Wie konnte sie den heiraten?"
Ich sage nur eines: Geld war es nicht.
>> SALLY: Dein Körper.
>> MURAT: Mein Körper war es. Genau.
Ihr könnt das glauben. Es war einfach mein Körper.
Ja.
Ja, cool, aber
cool. Das gefällt mir jetzt.
>> SALLY: Das war dein Wunschrezept.
>> MURAT: Ja. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, das habe ich
– noch vor einer Woche habe ich noch das gewünscht,
dass ich mal gern so was hätte
wie einen Burger nur als Kuchen,
einen Burgerkuchen.
Ja.
Leibniz Butterkekse?
>> SALLY: Nur echt
>> MURAT: Nur echt mit 48 Zähnen.
>> SALLY: Nein, 52.
>> MURAT: Nee, die haben anscheinend
die Menge reduziert in der Verpackung.
Es sind nur noch 48 statt 52 Zähne.
>> SALLY: Nee.
>> MURAT: Ja, doch.
Nicht?
>> SALLY: Glaub es mir. Ich habe sie gezählt.
>> MURAT: Wow!
Oh! Ist das cool!
Weißt du, was mir
– ich weiß nicht, ob es funktionieren könnte.
Wenn man das einfriert, könnte man das auch als Eis essen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Gell?
>> SALLY: Es ist halt dann nicht so ein cremiges Eis wie...
Er beißt wirklich wie in ein Sandwich rein.
Es ist nicht so ein cremiges Eis wie Eis am Stiel,
weil ja die Sahne jetzt zu viel Feuchtigkeit, zu viel Wasser hat.
Aber man könnte es machen.
>> MURAT: Boah!
>> SALLY: Weißt du nicht mehr?
Ich habe doch mal diese Fürst-Pückler-Schnitte gemacht.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Vom Eis so ein bisschen...
>> MURAT: Ja, ja.
Ideal zu meiner Stoffwechseldiät, die ich gerade mache.
Bei mir ist Stoffwechsel eh etwas anderes.
Ich wechsle halt dauernd meine Kleidung.
Ja.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Immer eine Nummer größer.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Ich würde das eher
wie ein normaler Mensch essen
mit Gabel und Löffel.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich wollte nichts sagen.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich wollte dich nicht stören.
>> MURAT: Nein, ich sage ja...
Wisst ihr, woran das liegt?
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> MURAT: Wenn du auf dem Bau arbeitest
und du isst etwas,
dann hast du halt keinen Teller, Messer oder Gabel.
Das können nur Sachen sein,
die du kurz in die Hand rein nimmst.
Manchmal haben wir auch kein Buttermesser.
Dann nehmen wir den Meterstab zum Beispiel.
Ja, haben wir auch schon benutzt. Ja.
Oder eine Schraube.
>> SALLY: Zum Umrühren des Kaffees?
>> MURAT: Zum Umrühren, ja, vom Kaffee
nehmen wir immer eine Schraube.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Okay...
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Gut?
Wie ist so das Verhältnis zwischen Säure,
Süße,
>> MURAT: Ich habe ein gutes Verhältnis zu dem Kuchen.
>> SALLY: Frucht,
>> SALLY: Cremigkeit?
>> MURAT: Hammer!
>> SALLY: Knackig,
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: luftig?
>> SALLY: Habe ich jetzt alle Adjektive benutzt?
>> MURAT: Für mich, ja. Knackig, luftig.
Voll lecker!
>> SALLY: Süß,
>> MURAT: Ehrlich!
>> SALLY: manchmal sauer.
>> MURAT: Hammer!
>> SALLY: Vor allem morgens vor elf.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Macht das unbedingt nach!
Das schmeckt echt klasse. Ehrlich, ohne Spaß.
>> SALLY: Ja?
>> MURAT: Ja ich bin voll...
Diesmal muss ich gar nicht lügen.
Es stimmt.
>> SALLY: Ich wollte eigentlich das als No-Bake machen,
aber ich habe unten, wenn du es gemerkt hast
in deinem Sandwich...
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Die weiche Schicht, das war ein Biskuit.
>> MURAT: Habe ich gar nicht gemerkt.
>> SALLY: Ich habe praktisch auf den Keks
einen Biskuit gebacken.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Aber man könnte es auch No-Bake machen,
wenn man den Biskuit weglässt.
Aber ich glaube, ich finde es so ganz cool,
damit es nicht zu viel Creme ist im Verhältnis zu...
>> MURAT: Finde ich auch.
>> SALLY: Ist gut?
>> MURAT: Ich habe gar nichts gemerkt.
Ich habe nur gemerkt, das schmeckt einfach gut.
Ich habe auch gar nicht...
Ich muss – ganz ehrlich, ich habe nur auf den Keks geachtet,
sonst gar nichts.
Und sonst wirklich nichts. Also...
>> SALLY: Okay.
Also, falls ihr das Rezept nachmachen wollt,
dann findet ihr es in meiner App,
auf meinem YouTube Channel, in meinem Blog.
Und wie gesagt, habe ich jetzt hier 20 Portionen...
>> MURAT: Oder ihr findet das jetzt auf der Baustelle jetzt gleich.
>> SALLY: Oder jetzt auf der Baustelle.
Aber bis ihr das Video schaut, ist es leider schon vorbei.
Denn ich habe es letzte Woche gedreht.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich habe jetzt hier 20 Portionen gemacht,
also mit 20 Keks-Stückchen,
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Keks-Sandwich-Kuchen.
>> SALLY: Ihr könnt das natürlich auch umrechnen.
Also ich würde es auch im Blog jetzt als 20 mal angeben.
Dann könnt ihr auch sagen:
–  keine Ahnung –
"Ich mache 40."
Aber momentan macht wohl keiner ein ganzes Blech.
>> MURAT: Ja, aber ich finde jetzt auch, wenn...
Im Kindergarten oder so
ist es eine ganze coole Portion, finde ich.
Also
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: wenn ihr einen Kindergarten habt, der...
Also, sobald mal wieder Geburtstage stattfinden
und Feierlichkeiten, finde ich,
ist das halt auch ein richtig cooler Kuchen,
den man größer skalieren kann
und einfach eine größere Menge zubereiten kann,
weil man es eben auch schön teilen kann.
Und ich glaube, gerade für Kinder ist es auch schön.
Ich kenne auch diesen Butterkekskuchen,
den man
– wo man einfach so jeden Keks noch einzeln dekoriert.
Und dann ist es auch so ein Geburtstagskuchen.
>> MURAT: Ja, aber das ist dann wieder zu viel Arbeit,
>> MURAT: muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
>> SALLY: Ja, finde ich auch.
>> SALLY: Also so finde ich es perfekt.
>> MURAT: Hm, echt cool.
Wenn wir jetzt noch tolle Fotos hätten von der Sarah,
>> SALLY: Das wäre der Wahnsinn.
>> MURAT: das wäre der Wahnsinn.
>> SALLY: Dann holen wir uns mal Sarah, die Schnitte.
>> MURAT: Ja, Sarah, mach mal ein paar.
Genau.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich schneide dir das noch an, Sarah.
Und dann darfst du.
Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und falls ihr Rezeptwünsche habt,
schreibt sie einfach in die Kommentare.
>> MURAT: Ja, macht das auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Wenn ihr bis hierher geschaut habt,
dann schreibt doch in die Kommentare: "Murat, du Schnitte."
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Du süß-saure Schnitte.
>> MURAT: O ja...
Hör auf, Sally. Wir sind verheiratet.
Bis dann!
Tschüss!
Kann ich da gerade mitnehmen die drei Reihen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Ja.
[Musik]